COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME. TO OUR
HEARING THIS MORNING IN WHICH
TO THE KOBE NINETEEN AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
ATTEMPT IN MY LIMIT NOT GATHER
IN THE NEAR TO SOURCE DISTANCE.
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
WITH THE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY TO NORMAL IN
ORDER ENSURE THE PUBLIC TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLIER COMMITTEE
C. COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE
CAPITOL ON THERE ARE NO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS FOR THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WE WILL USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO
THAT. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-692-8953 I WILL SAY
THAT AGAIN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO
FIVE SIX NINE ZERO NINE. YEAH
AND THAT IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE
SIX NINE ZERO NINE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW IT
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE ENERGY
COMMITTEE WEBSITES. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE. THERE MAY BE-A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
A QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND
YOU WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE AND
THEN OR THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND IT TO
AVOID ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST TO MUTE THE DEVICE YOU
WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE THAT
REMEMBER WHEN YOU CALL ME THE
DEVICE YOU'RE LISTENING THAT
WAY WE CAN HEAR YOU CLEARLY.
OBVIOUSLY I MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IT'S
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. IT'S ALSO A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYBODY
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL. YOUR TESTIFIED TESTIFYING
ON. AND PLEASE RAIN FROM PRIOR
TESTIMONY AND RE LITIGATING
THE- POLICY MERITS AS WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THE FISCAL ISSUES.
WHEN EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS. AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN A CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SOME LAG
TIMES- FOR THE PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE OBVIOUSLY
EVERYBODY BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE HEARD. WE HAVE FORTY ONE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA AND ALL
OF THEM ALL OF THEM ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. SUSPENDS
FIVE CANDIDATES. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM SO MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CENTER PORTANTINO I'M
HERE PORTANTINO HERE CENTER
BATES SENATOR BRADFORD YOUR
BRADFORD HERE SENATOR JONES.
JONES HERE SENATOR KAMLAGER
HERE KAMLAGER HERE LAYERED HERE
PLAYER HERE MICHALSKI. FIVE
MEMBERS PRESENT WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO THE BUSINESS OF THE FILE DO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
WANTED HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. I'LL BE IT'S
INSTITUTING A TIME LIMIT ON
WITNESS TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED THREE MINUTES
OF TOTAL TIME FOR PRIMARY
TESTIMONY ALL OTHER WISHING ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. IF NECESSARY WE
WILL LIMIT THE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY TO TWELVE MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE AS A REMINDER ALL
WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL IMPACT
OF THE BILL. AND PLEASE DON'T.
REPEAT PRIOR TESTIMONY WHEN WE
GET TO THE ME TOOS OBVIOUSLY
THAT'LL BE STRICTLY ENFORCED
WITH NAME. AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. AND I WILL MAKE SURE
WE TRY TO KEEP TO THAT. OUR
FIRST BILL IS SB FIVE FROM
SENATOR GLAZER ON UC REGENTS
STUDENT MEMBERS- THIS IS. A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MISTER
GLAZERS WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SAYING NONE- WE WILL MOVE
TO THIS IS A CA FIVE THIRTY ONE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ISEE NO ONE
THERE- SO WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WAITING TO
SUPPORT THIS ON OUR
TELECONFERENCE ON MODERATORS OR
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE WHO WISHES
TO SUPPORT S. C. A. FIVE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO IN
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE DO
HAVE TWO LINES INTO JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GET.
PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. AGAIN WILL IF YOU DO
WHAT WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS THIS
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN WE'RE
PROVIDING LINE NUMBERS TO THOSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS MOMENT. WE'LL
GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MORNING MR TURN MEMBER
EXPLAINED THAT THE BURKE ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. BY.
THIRTEEN WE SEEM TO HAVE LOST
LINE THIRTEEN IF YOU WOULD
WOULD LIKE TO PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN. WE'LL OPEN THE LINE
UP. LOSSES AMONG. WE JIM CROW
LAWS THAT LINE ENTIRELY- YOU
MAY CONTINUE WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
OW MOVE ON TO THE OPPOSITION
OF A CA FIVE THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM HERE TO OPPOSE US CA
FIVE I SEE NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WHO IS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO S. C. A. FIVE.
DESPITE OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN
TAKEN THE SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
OF A CA FIVE WILL COME BACK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BIZANA DEREK DO YOU HAVE A FILE
ON S. C. A. FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JULIAN IT
HERE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. A YES THEY DO HAVE A
FILE. AT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
INDICATES THE MEASURE CREATES
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED FORTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS LIKELY IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. FOR MATERIALS
ASSOCIATED WITH ADDING A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT TO A
STATEWIDE ELECTION BALLOT. ONLY
THE USED A MINOR AN OBSERVABLE
COSTS THIS RELATED TO THIS
MEASURE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE SIGNAL HANDS GO UP.
OR ANY QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A CA FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO A BEFORE
BY MR ARAMBULA DR EMIL ON
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE ITEM AND DOCTOR AND
REALIZE WAY PRESENTATION SO
MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL GO TO ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO IN
THEIR MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT AB FOUR. TEND TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE A LINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
ALL THE PROVIDER LINE NUMBER
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
NIELSEN. AWESOME CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN COURT THANK YOU. WE
DO HAVE ONE ON THE LINE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM THE LINE NUMBER.
ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NICOLE BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE SEEMED TO
THIS TIME MR SURE ALL RIGHT
HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO AND AB
FOUR. NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB FOUR. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVE AN TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION- WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AMAZON A DIRTY OF THE
FILE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACTS.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE COST
EXTEND ELIGIBILITY TO ADULTS
AGE TWENTY SIX YEARS AND OLDER
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. ONE BILLION OF
WHICH WOULD BE GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AT FIVE POINT FOUR BILLION FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION OF WHICH
WOULD BE GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. I'D LIKE TO ADD
THAT ASSUMING LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL. OF EITHER AB OR SB
ONE THIRTY THREE THREE ONE
THIRTY THREE OF WHICH ARE THE
HEALTH. A TRAILER BILLS. AT THE
COST TO EXPAND FOR SCOPE COME
AND- WHICH WOULD EXPAND.
COVERAGE AND- A GIFT AND- OLDER
REGARD OF IN THE STATUS- THIS
BILL WOULD RESULT IN A- COSTS
OF ACROSS ONE. DOLLAR GENERAL
IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND THREE ONE
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON ON
GOING BASIS. I WOULD NOTE THAT
DOES THIS TEST DOES NOT ADJUST
FOR THE DIFFERENT
IMPLEMENTATION DATES. BETWEEN
EIGHTY SB ONE THIRTY THREE AND
THE SPELL. FINALLY FISCAL
IMPACTS ARE INCLUSIVE OF THE
COST OF THE. IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR
THAT WE WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SAYING NO HANDS GO
UP AND NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A SB FOUR WILL GO TO
SUS FENCE. MOVING ON AB ONE
TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
WEEKLY BENEFIT AMOUNTS THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
GO RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORTIVE OF AB ONE TWENTY
THREE. IT IS BIG IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE TWENTY THREE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
FIRST CORDYLINE. TWENTY FOUR. I
GRAN RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AB ONE ELEVEN Q. ONE MOMENT
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN GO
AHEAD PLACE. WHEN IT'S YOUR
TURN MEMBERS WILLIAM MCMAHON
BURKE ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE SEEMED TO
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TWENTY
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION AB. ONE TWENTY
THREE. AND TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER JERRY OF
KNOWING QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION- WE WILL MOVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS A
DIRTY A FIVE ON AB TWENTY
THREE. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. EMPLOYMENT DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES BILL INCREASE PAID
FAN LEAVE PAYMENTS TO ABOUT
HUNDRED TO SIX DOLLAR IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO. ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY THREE AND ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS ON GOING UP
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
FROM THE EMPLOYMENT
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
DISABILITY FUND. ADDITIONALLY
EDT ESTIMATES THE BILL CREATES
THREE POINT THREE MILLION. AND
GENERAL FUND COSTS TO UPDATE
OUR INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS DEVELOP NEW BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS AND PROVIDE
EDUCATION OUTREACH TO
BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYEES.
REGARDING THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE SIMILAR HANDS GO UP
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB ONE TWENTY THREE IS MOVED TO
SUSPECTS MOVING ON TO AB TWO
THREE THREE. FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH- PUBLIC
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION UC
ADMISSIONS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO SUPPORT
AB TWO THREE THREE. IT IS BIG
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO THREE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION. OF A AB TWO THREE
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM COMING TO OPPOSE. OF ANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. TWO THREE THREE.
AND TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWO THREE THREE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN COMING UP.
ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO FINANCE
MS ON THE DIRTY HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATES THE BILL REQUIRES
FOUR TO EIGHT ADDITIONAL FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT ADMISSIONS
STAFF. AT EACH OF THE NINE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES INCREASE
ASSOCIATED ONGOING SALARY AND
BENEFIT COSTS OF TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION TO FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. A FINANCING
KERR SAID THAT THE BILL RESULT
IN ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD.
ALTHOUGH IT ISN'T CLEAR THAT
THE WORKLOAD INCREASED WOULD
REQUIRE OF THE LEVEL OF REACHED
RESOURCES. PREVIOUSLY
IDENTIFIED. WE ESTIMATE GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. ASSUMING IT'S
REVISIONS COULD BE IMPLEMENTED
WITH TWO ADDITIONAL FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT ADMISSIONS STAFF AT
EACH. OTHER CAMPUSES. THESE
PRESSURES ARE ESTIMATED TO
BEGIN IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND BECOME FULLY
EFFECTIVE IN. TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE WHEN THE BILL
REQUIRES FULL IMPLEMENTATION.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT MR
ACCOUNTS HE HAS A QUESTION OF
WHICH IS A COMMON MISTER CHAIRS
REALLY DISHEARTENING THAT. OVER
TO THE SIX YEAR PERIOD THE UC
SYSTEM HASN'T HAS ADMITTED
SIXTY FOR. NON STUDENT ATHLETES
AS STUDENT ATHLETES BASED ON
THE DONATIONS OF THEIR OF THEIR
FAMILY AND THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO. EIGHT NEW STAFF PEOPLE
TO STOP THAT PRACTICE AND TO
PAY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS SEEMS
IN PAIN CREDIBLE I'M IN AYE. I
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT THE UC
SYSTEM COULD JUST STOP IT
WITHOUT HAVING TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL PERSONS IN THAT WE
COULD CHANGE. HAS IT A STAFF
REPORTS INDICATES CHANGE THE
CULTURE THAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH SO OBVIOUSLY I KNOW
IT'S GOING TO SUSPENSE BUT I
JUST WANT THOUGHT THAT. WE NEED
TO TAKE NOTED THAT. I CAN. IS
THAT A YOUR HAND UP NO. ONE
COMMENT THERE SEEING OTHER COM
FOR THAT OBJECTION AB TWO THREE
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
AGAIN MY BOERNER HORVATH ON
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. AND UC ADMISSIONS.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION OF
A RIGHT TO SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM SUPPORT OF.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WISHING TO SUPPORT AB.
TWELVE FIFTEEN. IT IS BIG IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE ONE TWO
ONE FIVE CALL FIFTEEN RATHER.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. SURE WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB. TWELVE
FIFTEEN. IN SPEAKING OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. BIZCHAIR
WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP OUR I
HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WE WILL MOVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE A FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ESTIMATES THE BILL
CREATES ON GOING COST PRESSURES
OF ONE POINT SIX MILLION TO ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY CREDIT STAFF HOURS FOR
BOTH EMISSIONS COMPLIANCE
ACTIVITIES. AND EMISSIONS AUDIT
ACTIVITIES. R. THANK YOU OF
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
MOVES TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO AB
TWO FORTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ ON LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WORKFORCE
ASSESSMENTS. THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. AND WE ARE OPENING
UP PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
OKAY ME IN THIS ROOM IS NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY NINERS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR ZERO. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR
ZERO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO FIRST- LINE.
TWENTY FOUR. PINE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ANDREA RIVERA BUT THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BY. TWENTY MATALIN COOPER FROM
THE OFTEN WORK MORE ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING COUNTIES
CONTRA COSTA SAN DIEGO AND
YELLOW ON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PINE. FIFTEEN PINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE.
PINE FIFTEEN IT SOUNDED LIKE
YOU MAY HAVE JUST CHECKED YOUR
MUTE FEATURES WE'RE TAKING OUT
OF QUEUE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN AT THIS
TIME. GOOD LINE. TWENTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING DONNA THANKS
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO FORTY THANK YOU. PINE.
FIFTEEN NICOLE ORLANDO. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN CUBA STRUCTURE
ALL RIGHT WILL NOT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY FOUR OR
TWO FOUR ZERO THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB. TWO
FOUR ZERO. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO FOUR ZERO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MR SURE WE HAVE NO AN
NGO. ALL RIGHT HAVE A TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITIONAL MOVED TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS THERE
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS A STATE HAS ALREADY
ALLOCATED THREE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT FOR PUBLIC HEALTH TO
PERFORM A RETROACTIVE REVIEW
THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO THE
CURVE IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
A PROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS OF
OVERALL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF THIS
ANALYSIS WILL INFORM A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY ALLOCATE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. WE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. IT HAS EXISTING
AUTHORITY TO PERFORM THE BILL'S
ACTIVITY. DO YOU THANK YOU
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY TWO FOUR
ZERO WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON AB FIVE EIGHT ZERO BY
RODRIGUEZ SUBMERGENCE HE
SERVICES VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE SEVEN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY- IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO SUPPORT AB FIVE
EIGHTY. AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE EIGHT ZERO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCHTONE
FALL. WHO I DO HAVE FIVE STRING
UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE. TWENTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROD BREWER FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FIVE EIGHTY. LINE TWENTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DAN- CONFESS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
CALLING IN SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT ZERO. MR HERE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT HAVE A
TAKEN SUPPORT REMOVED
OPPOSITION. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FOR FIVE FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB. FIVE EIGHTY.
AND TO SPEAK IN A POSITION OF
AB FIVE EIGHTY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR SURELY
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ARE I HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL
MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR FILE. HE MISTER
KERR CAL OVS INDICATES IT WILL
REQUIRE SIX POSITIONS AND ONE
POINT. TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE STILL I WOULD NOTE THAT ANY
REQUEST FOR RESOURCES WILL BE
ANALYZED DURING THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. ADDITIONALLY WE
NOTE THAT THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT INCLUDES RESOURCES
FOR CAL- YES TO A STYLISH NEW
OFFICES EQUITY- AND TO THE
EXTENT THE OFFICES. BUT
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS COMMUNITY
OF THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
MAY HELP OFFSET A PORTION OF
CARILLO YES IS ESTIMATED COSTS.
LASTLY ALTHOUGH THIS BILL
DOESN'T GO TO MANDATES
DISCLAIMER. BECAUSE THE BILL
REQUIRES COUNTIES TO SEND THEIR
EMERGENCY PLANS TO CALLAWAY S.
REVIEW. BUT WE ANTICIPATE THE
COSTA COUNTY TO SEND THESE
PLANS TO- YES WILL LIKELY
LIKELY BE LESS THAN ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT
SEEING THEIR QUESTIONS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES. THAT OBJECTION AB
FIVE EIGHTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON S. B. AB
FOUR SEVEN FOUR FOUR BY
RODRIGUEZ ON STATE ROUTE EIGHTY
THREE RELINQUISHMENT. CANADA
SUSPENDS CANDIDATE IN THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT. NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN FOUR FOUR.
THIS BEACON SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
FOUR FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN FOUR FOUR THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSES COMPANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY ONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB.
SEVEN FOUR FOUR. IT SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SEVEN FOUR
FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE MISTER SURE WAY
OF KNOWING CHEWING UP ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITY NOW WILL CHECK IN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I HAVE NO
FILE ON MAY. WE DO NOT HAVE A
FILE AND I HAVE NO CLUE SO TAT
OF. A SEVEN FOUR. WILL GO
SUSPEND WILL MOVE TO A TWO
SHIMMY THREE TWO SIX- BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- ON HEALTH CARE
SIR PLAN CONSUMER PURCHASE.
THIS IS CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAVE PRESENTATION. AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FORTY- SHE ME AB
THREE TWENTY SIX THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE TO SIX. SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE TWO SIX PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR. YOUR
AVAILABLE TO CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK AND A
SCOPE AND A CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MR HERE WHERE NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE TWENTY SIX. RECOVERY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB THREE
TO SIX. THAT IS BIG IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THEN MR SURE WAY
OF KNOWING QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION-
WE WILL NOW GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE ESTIMATES THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH IS STILL RANGE
BETWEEN TEN THOUSAND AND ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS MANAGED CARE
FUND ANNUALLY BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY. READ
SEE OR WITNESS THE AWARDS I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DOES HAVE DISCRETION
TO AWARD UP TO THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. FINALLY THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES THE COST
ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM ON AN
ONGOING BASIS WOULD BE MINOR
AND CIRCLE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR THAT SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY SIX. GO TO SUSPENSE
REMOVING ON AB THREE FIVE SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN HAS NOT
WAY PRESENTATION ON THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE- AND SO HE'S
HERE TO PRESENT. AND PLEASE
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS OF THE BILL
THIS IS ON FEROCITY THANK YOU
MR I'D REALLY APPRECIATE IT I
JUST WANTED TO HAVE A BRIEF
CONVERSATION THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HEALTH- IS
ALLOWED TO CHARGE A FEE FOR THE
TEMPORARY PERMIT TO MINISTER
THE CERTIFICATION WHICH WILL
LEAD TO BE COST NEUTRAL. WITH
THAT I WILL END MY PRESENTATION
THANK YOU FOR CARE ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORTERS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. I UNDERSTAND THAT BRIAN
SPENCER WANTS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL YOU SEE ON
THE PHONE LINE. WE HAD NO AND
DIALING IN AS A CO HOST ON
MISTER SPENCER IF YOU WOULD
LIKE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT IS ON THE
REGULAR LAWN. ALL PARDON ME.
DO
YOU HAVE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL MOVE ON WE'RE NOT
RESOLUTION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSES ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED. AB. THREE FIVE
SIX. TO SPEAK IN THE SUPPORT.
DEPARTMENT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE A LINE
CUED UP LINE TWELVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. SHARES RIGHT SPENCER I
ACTUALLY WASN'T CUTE SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF COLLEGE EYES I SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COULD BE ATTIC MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSORED
MEASURE AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
CAN STONE ADVOCATE FOR THE
OTHER CO SPONSOR THE
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION WE JUST
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS HUNDREDS IN FEES SUPPORTED.
ZERO GENERAL FUND IMPACT
MEASURE THANK YOU. HI IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION AB. THREE
FIVE SIX. BUT WE HAVE NO IN
QUEUED UP FROM THE PHONE LINES
ARE I HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL MOVE TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ESTIMATES THE TOTAL COST
OF IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STILL
IS SIX HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME. FROM THE
RADIATION CONTROL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
AND TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. AS THE AUTHOR NOTED
THE BILL DOES REQUIRE PUBLIC
HEALTH TO CHARGE A FEE IN ORDER
TO RECOVER. PUBLIC HEALTH
REASONABLE COST YOU MISTER THIS
TEMPORARY PERMIT PROCESS. ALL
RIGHT HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
FINANCE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES MR CHEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME INDULGENCES CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU.
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE FIVE SIX.
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON
AB THREE SIX SEVEN BY. MS
GARCIA ON MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
AND WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE IS NOBODY HERE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THEIR-
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. OF AB THREE
SIX SEVEN. TO SPEAK OF SUPPORT
OF AB THREE SIX SEVEN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL
FIRST GO TO LINE. TWELVE BRENT
SPENCER I'M HAPPY MERICAN
COLLEGES OBGYN STIFF AT NINE IN
SUPPORT. LINE. EIGHTEEN MORNING
MR TURN NUMBERS BLAME AT THE
BURKE ON BEHALF OF NEIGHBOR
APPROACH WITH CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. LINE.
TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU CARE
MEMBERS KATHY DOWN AUSTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION BEGINNING BIRTH
CITY WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. BELIED. BUT MAY LINE
TWENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CATHERINE SHU ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF STUDENT COUNCILS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE FOURTEEN. HI MY
NAME IS JOBS INCREASE ON ON
BEHALF OF THIS INCIDENT FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND WE ARE IN THE CORNER AS AB
THREE SIX SEVEN THANK YOU. THIS
IS YOUR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN OUR
SUPPORT LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION.
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE NO THERE'S ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY NO IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
SIX SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTEEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE- I'D LIKE A FEW
MOMENTS TO- SPEAK MY OPPOSITION
THANK YOU HAVE NO PRIMARY
WITNESS SUPPOSED SO YOU HAD TO
PROMOTE POLICIES THAT THAT
THAT'LL YOU HAD TO PRE REGISTER
PLEASE TELL US YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
CALIFORNIA IS ON THE FIGHTER
CARE WORRIED ABOUT ONE TO OUR
NEXT SPEAKER THANK YOU. I HAVE
NO NO SINCE YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL MOVE TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU SHARE. THIS BILL COULD
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE AND IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. WOULD KNOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE-
INDICATE NO STATE OPERATIONS
COST IMPLEMENT THE STILL. THE
CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
INDICATES THAT ANNUAL COST
IMPLEMENT. SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO SUPPLY ADDITIONAL
PRODUCTS ON CAMPUS HEALTH
CENTERS AND FINALLY THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
INDICATES THAT COSTS RESULTING
FROM THE BILL OR MINOR
ANSWERABLE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANY QUESTIONS ON AB THREE SIX
SEVEN SAYING NINE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE SIX SEVEN.
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE FOR MOVING
ON AB THREE NINETY ONE. ON
POLLINATOR HABITAT CONSERVATION
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE WHO
THE WHO. WHO THE- AND THIS ITEM
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. AND
WE ARE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE AND THERE'S NOBODY HERE
TO TESTIFY THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
MODERATORS OR ANYONE. IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE NINE ONE.
SPEAKING SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILLIAM AT THE BURKE- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BEEKEEPERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. AND NO ONE ELSE DURING
UP IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT
WILL MOVED OPPOSITION ANYBODY
OPPOSED AB. THREE NINETY ONE.
SOMEBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES. STAY UP NOT
POSITION OF AB THREE NINE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE'S NO ONE
COMING UP ON THE PHONE LINES AT
THIS TIME ARE HAVING TICKETS
FOR IN OPPOSITION WILL COME
BACK TO FINANCE. THANK YOU IN
TO THE DEPARTMENT O FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE IF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IS
APPROPRIATED FOR THIS BILL.
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT ONE POSITION. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT WHILE THE BILL
DOESN'T PROVIDE AN
APPROPRIATION OF THE BILL DOES
RESULT IN A FUTURE GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURE. ALL RIGHT HAVING
HEARD FROM FINANCING THE
QUESTIONS ARE HANDS GOT FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THREE NINE ONE. STABILITY
SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB FOUR
SIXTY ONE. FROM THE SAME AUTHOR
ON CAL WORKS WELFARE TO WORK.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OF THREE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SIXTY ONE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOUR SIX ONE. ONCE AGAIN THE TO
OPEN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE ONE THAT IS CHEWING UP
PLEASE ALLOW A MOMENT TO
PROVIDE LINE NUMBER. BY NUMBER
TWENTY NINE TO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE MORE MATURE
MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS
PARTS AFTER QUESTIONS AROUND
MOM POVERTY WILL TRY TO BE A
SPONSOR AND WEREN'T SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
INTO AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB
FOUR SIX ONE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THE SHOPPING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. OPPOSED AB.
FOUR SIX ONE. LIKE TO SPEAK OUT
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR SIX
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE SHOWING UP IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING
HEARD HEARD FROM SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WILL MOVE TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I KNOW
FILE MR. WE HAVE NO FILE ON
THIS AND WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
ON THIS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOUR SIX ONE. VOTER SUSPENSE.
MOVING DAY BEFORE- FOUR BY
SEVEN MEMBER SALAS ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION MEDICAL LEGAL
EXPENSES OF FEE SCHEDULE. THIS
IS SPENT CAN MAKE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. AND WILL GO
TO SUPPORT TESTIMONY THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR OH FOUR. LIKE TO SPEAK OUT
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR OH FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THERE IS NO ONE
COMING UP IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WOULD
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR OH FOR
THIS COMPANY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES OPPOSED AB FOUR OH
FOUR. WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK OUT
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR OH
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND THERE'S NO
ONE DOING UP IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WATER
ACTUALLY MEET PHARMA FINANCE.
THANK YOU AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
THE RULE MAKING COSTS TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL WOULD BE
OBSERVABLE WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES. BECAUSE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS SUCH A LARGE
WORKFORCE THE STATE WILL LIKELY
INCUR AN UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
IMPACT IF THIS BILL IS ENACTED
AND A QUALIFIED MEDICAL
EXAMINERS. ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
HIGHER REIMBURSEMENT RATES
STREAMLINED TO DISPEL. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES AB FOUR OH FOUR WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. WE ON AB 4185%
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIET THE
DAUGHTERS. THIS IS AN EMERGENCY
SERVICES. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CAN MAKE THE OPPOSITE WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM HAVE A ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOUR EIGHTEEN. IF YOU LIKE
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
EIGHTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE'S
NO ONE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB. FOUR
EIGHTEEN. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PLACE YOURSELF INTO IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR EIGHTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO OF WANTING TO
ORDER LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
THAT'S TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS- ACTUALLY IS ROD DREHER
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
CALLING IN SUPPORT. OF AB FOUR
EIGHTEEN ADJUSTING AFTER THE
CALL AND WHAT A LINE FROM
EARLIER MY APOLOGIES. ANYONE
ELSE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION HE
WOULD BE A START. EIGHTEEN AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME I
HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES FOR A
BEFORE EIGHTEEN. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S A FILE FORMER FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO THE
EXTENT AN APPROPRIATION IS
PROVIDED FOR THE SCRAP PROGRAM
HELLO YES INDICATES THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD OF
ADMINISTERING THE GRANTS WOULD
NOT BE ADORABLE WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES AND WOULD USE THE
PRESCRIBE SET ASIDE IN THE BILL
FOR GRANTS MANAGEMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION. FURTHER THEY
INDICATE THAT THAT PRESCRIBE 3%
SET ASIDE MAY BE INSUFFICIENT
TO TAKE ON THE WORKLOAD AND
COULD NEED UP 25% OF ANY
APPROPRIATION PROVIDED. WE KNOW
THAT OTHER THIS BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE AN APPROPRIATION AND
THE CREATION OF THE PROGRAM
ITSELF DOES NOT HAVE A FISCAL
IMPACT. THE BILL DOES CREATE A
FUTURE GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FOR EIGHTEEN. WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A
REPORT TWENTY ONE BY SIMPLY
MEMBER WARD ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CAREER DEVELOPMENT
COLLEGE PREP. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO TO
SUPPORT. IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR TWO ONE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR TWO ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE IS GOING TO BRING UP IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY ONE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED AB FOUR TWO
ONE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. AB FOUR
TWO ONE. PUT YOURSELF IN THE
CUTE FROM OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR
TWO ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE'S
NO ONE DOING UP IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. OUR HAVING TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR
TO ONE- WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU USING
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENT DATA.
COULD CREATE ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES OF
UP TO TWENTY TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS DIFFERENT
ADDITIONAL CAREER DEVELOPMENT
AND COLLEGE PREP ENTITIES. ARE
DEPENDING ON THE NUMBER OF
COURSE THAT SHIFT TO USING A
SENSE A STATE BASIS RATHER THAN
A POSITIVE ATTENDANCE METHOD-
ALTHOUGH THIS ESTIMATE ASSUMES
ALL COURSES WE TRANSITION FROM
USING A SENSE OF STATE BASIS
RATHER THAN A POSITIVE
ATTENDANCE METHOD. AN UNKNOWN
NUMBER OF CD CD COURSE. YOU
CERVANTES ATTENDANCE METHOD.
LASTLY WE EXPECT OF MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE COSTS FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM FINANCE AND I SEE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. EIGHTY FOUR
TO ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON AB FIVE FOURTEEN ALSO
BY SEVEN MEMBER WARD ON
INJUNCTIONS UNTER. UNDERTAKING
CIVIL ACTIONS DISTRIBUTION OF
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT MATERIALS
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OPPOSITE WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
SUPPORT SOMEBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE THERE'S NOBODY
AROUND TWENTY FOURTEEN. VOTERS
OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE FOURTEEN. BADERINWA. I
APOLOGIZE I WASN'T ME MOVING
OUT AT THAT MOMENT IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE'S NO ONE COMING UP IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSE YOUR COMPANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED. BOUNDARIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FIVE FOURTEEN. IF
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK OUT IN
OPPOSITION ON AB FIVE FOURTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE'S NO
WARNING QUEUE IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT HAVE A
TAKE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
OF. AB FIVE FOURTEEN REMOVED
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I DON'T HAVE A
FILE ON THIS MEASURE DO NOT
HAVE A FILE AND I DO NOT HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE FOURTEEN.
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
AB FIVE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN.
PROGRAM OF ALL INCLUSIVE ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY.
TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
GO TO SUPPORT POSITIONS THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
VERSION OF A ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINES FOR AB FIVE TWO THREE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE TWO THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE DO HAVE ONE THAT'S BEING
PROVIDED THEIR LINE NUMBER AT
THIS TIME ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ELEVEN BY ELEVEN YEAR OLD. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO GO OVER IN THE CAPITAL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF WILL BE
HELD AT THE PORT THANK YOU. AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE COULD UP IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION AND
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE WISHING TO COME TESTIFY
OPPOSED AB FIVE TWO THREE.
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSED. TO ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB FIVE TWO THREE.
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE TWO THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE IS NO ONE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE MOVED APARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DO YOU HAVE A FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD FOR
THE CENTRALIZED APPLICATIONS
BRANCH WITH AN ANNUAL ESTIMATED
COST OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WE ESTIMATE THAT THESE
THESE COSTS ARE LIKELY
OBSERVABLE WITHIN THE LICENSING
AND CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FUND
AND WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EXISTING POSITIONAL AUTHORITY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT I
SEE NO HANDS GO UP SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE TWO THREE.
VOTER SUSPENSE WILL MOVE ON AB
SEVEN FORTY NINE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES MEDICAL DIRECTOR SHE
TO THE CATION. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT
TO SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY LOTTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN FORTY
NINE. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE'S NO ONE COMING UP IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION FOR S.
B. AB SEVEN FORTY NINE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE POSED TO AB SEVEN
FORTY NINE. LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN FORTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE'S NO ONE
COMING UP IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN
THE SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WILL
NOW GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HERE I'D LIKE TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT I HAD ACTUALLY NO
FILE FOR THE PRIMARY BILL AB
FIVE TWENTY THREE- AND FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY NINE THE
BILL THAT IS CURRENTLY UP- I
HAVEN'T THE SAME TESTIMONY THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES THE BILL WOULD CREATE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD WITH AN
ANNUAL COST OF ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND
THAT WE KNOW THAT THESE COSTS
ARE LIKELY OBSERVABLE WITHIN A
LYFT SYNCING AND CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM FUND A COULD I SKIP YOU
THE LAST TIME. NO YOU DID NOT
AYE I GOT AHEAD OF MYSELF AND-
I HAD NO FILE FOR HIS. MISTER
NAZARIAN EARLIER BILL. ALL
RIGHT SO WE'VE NOW HEARD FROM
FINANCE ON SEVEN FORTY NINE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION. A. B. SEVEN FORTY
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVIE
ON AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI. AND
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
COMMISSION. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO SUPPORT
TESTIMONY. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NO MAIN ROOM TWENTY FORTY-
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT. BECAUSE WORD OF
AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. HELLO
INTERIOR MINISTER. I CAN NOT
HEAR THE MODERATOR. I'M SORRY
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME NOW YES.
OKAY WE'RE WE DO AND DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TOP
POSITION OF AB FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE OPPOSED
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE OPPOSED AB FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT ON THE PHONE LINE. THIS
BEACON OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO THIS TIME. SURE WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP. OUR AYE WE
HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION FOR AB FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT- WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE OF A FILE. IF I AM
STILL HERE. WE HAVE NO FILE AND
I HAVE NO QUESTIONS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
WE'LL GO TO SUSPNSE MOVING ON
TO A B. SIX SIX SIX. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU ON SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IS THERE ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY NO.
BOUNDARIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
SIX SIX. IS BIG IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX SIX SIX PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS WILLIAM
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND SUPPORT.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE INTO IT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOT OPPOSITION FOR AB SIX SIX
SIX. NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED NUMBER A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED TO ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB SIX SIX
SIX. BUT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB SIX SIX SIX PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
IN QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF AB
SIX SIX SIX WILL GO TO
APARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO FILES
SHARE WE DON'T HAVE A FILE AND
I DON'T HAVE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX SIX SIX WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE- MOVIE MAY BE
TWELVE FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU. ON
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE MOTIONS TO
VACATE THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
AND WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF SUPPORTERS NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FIFTY DIED. THE SPEAKERS
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO INCLUDED
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE WILL
GO TO OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
FIFTY NINE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSED TO ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB TWELVE FIFTY
NINE. TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN
DOING UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AS THEIR A FILE ON
AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE. FILE
MISTER CHAIR NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE MOVED TO
SUSPENSE REMOVED AB SEVEN
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM ON PEACE OFFICERS
INVESTIGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF SUPPORTERS
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY AROUND FORTY.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN EIGHTEEN. THIS BEACON
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN EIGHTEEN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
LOWERED OUR Q. THAT MR. CAR
RIDE WITHOUT OPPOSITION. AB
SEVEN EIGHTEEN. N. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY SIR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVEN
EIGHTEEN. THIS BIG IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN EIGHTEEN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
IS THEIR FILE BERMAN INFINITY
CARE. NO FILE NO QUESTIONS- SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVEN
EIGHTEEN WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON A. B. SEVEN THIRTY BY
CORK SILVA ON ATHLETE AGENTS
MINOR ATHLETES HEALTH AND
SAFETY THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NINERS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE- IN SUPPORT.
AND TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN THIRTY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. SURE WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN THIRTY
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO HELP ANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB. SEVEN THIRTY.
AND TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVEN THIRTY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO INSURABLE. WE HAVE
NOBODY QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND WE WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON A. B.
SEVEN THIRTY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES NO SIGNIFICANT
STATISTICAL IMPACT TO CONFIDE
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL. WOULD NOTE THAT THE
MEASURE COULD LEAD TO
ADDITIONAL CASES ENTERING THE
COURT SYSTEM BY ADDING ACTIONS.
WIENER VIOLATIONS OF THE MILLER
I'LL ATHLETE AGENTS ACT. LASTLY
WE KNOW THE MEASURE COULD
IMPOSE NEW COSTS AND WORKLOAD
ON COUNTIES WHICH WOULD CREATE
ADDITIONAL FISCAL PRESSURE ON
THE LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. ARE I HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM FINANCING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVEN
THIRTY WILL GO TO SUSPEND. AB
SEVEN NINETY BY KIRK SILVA AND
CONSUMER LEGAL REMEDIES- THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION.
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE IN SUPPORT AND WE'LL
GO RIGHT TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
SEVEN NINETY ON THE PHONE LINE.
IS BIG IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
NINETY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE LINE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER. WE
WILL OPEN UP LINE SEVENTEEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIELLE KENDO
CRIES ARE ON BEHALF OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION AND THE NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CLINIC IN STRONG
SUPPORT. WE'RE GOING TO LISTEN
TO. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION
IS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO AB.
SEVEN NINETY. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO
ENSURE WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP.
ALL RIGHT HAVE A TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FILE
MISTER CHAIR NO FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SEVEN NINETY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING AB SEVEN FIFTY
THREE. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON ON THE UNDERGROUND
STORAGE TANK CLEANUP FUND THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO TAX MONEY'S
SUPPORTERS COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. SOMEBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN FIVE
THREE. IS BIG IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN FIVE THREE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE.
EIGHTEEN GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BYRD WILLIAM BUT THEN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA INTO PORT.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE CUED UP
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO TO OPPOSITION. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S A
MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY. SIR
ANYONE IN ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. AND TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE W
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT
WE'LL HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
ESTIMATES THE BILL WILL NOT
RESULT IN A FISCAL IMPACT TO
CONVENE A STAKEHOLDER GROUP OR
ANY ASSOCIATED WORKLOAD AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATED THE COST OF THE BILL
WOULD LIKELY BE MINOR
OBSERVABLE. WOULD NOTE THAT
THIS BILL AT THE FRONT IN THE
PROGRAM ARE CURRENTLY SCHEDULED
TO SUNSET IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX
AND BY EXTENDING THE SUNSET
DATE UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY SIX
THIS BILL CONTINUES EXISTING
ONGOING BASELINE REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES. THE WATER BOARD
CURRENTLY HAS AVERAGE ANNUAL
COST APPROXIMATELY TWENTY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THESE PURPOSES AND CD TFA ARE
AS AVERAGE ANNUAL PROGRAM COSTS
APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. BUT THEY WOULD
KNOW THAT THE BILL COULD RESULT
IN SIGNIFICANT FUTURE GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES. AND
POTENTIALLY LEAD TO REPURPOSE
SOME OF THE FUNDS AND ITS
RELATED SUB ACCOUNT- FOR
ADDITIONAL PURPOSES IN THE
FUTURE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
THAT SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVEN FIVE THREE.
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
THE A. B. I SAID IT'S AB SEVEN
FIVE THREE WITH A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON AB EIGHT. TO FIVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE ON
PERSONAL INFORMATION. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY SUPPORTERS
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
SEVEN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR TURNING ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT TO
FIVE. THIS WEEK IN SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE NOBODY CUTE APPLE GOT
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT TO FIVE-
SCENE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED SAY NO IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSES ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED EIGHTY EIGHT
TO FIVE. THIS WEEK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT TO FIVE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE LOADED UP MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHTS WAS TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL COME
BACK PARTMINER FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE INDICATES
THAT THE INCLUSION OF GENETIC
DATA THAT COULD LEAD TO AN
INCREASE IN VIOLATIONS OF THE
STATUTE WHICH COULD RESULT IN
COSTLY UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW
FUND OF TWO HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. ARE ANY
REQUEST FOR RESOURCES TO BE
EVALUATED DURING THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW THAT THE ENSURE
COMPETITION LAW FUND. WHICH
RECEIVES REVENUE PRIMARILY
THROUGH PENALTY ASSESSMENTS AS
A PROJECTED BALANCE OF TWO
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND MAY NOT BE ABLE TO ABSORB
THESE ADDITIONAL COSTS. LASTLY
STATE AGENCIES MAY INCUR
ADDITIONAL COST ISSUE ISSUE
DATA BREACH NOTIFICATIONS
RESULTING FROM THIS BILL- BUT
WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE LIKELY
TO BE MINOR OBSERVABLE. IF YOU
CURRENTLY. I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SEE
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LET ME LEVINE ON DOMESTIC.
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
THIS IS A SUSPENSECANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
WITH A RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. NOBODY WROTE FORTY TWO
OR THREE. SEVEN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY HIS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT BUT
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN THIS COMPANY ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NO MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY. WATER IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE GOT A SUPPORT
OPPOSITION NOW LET'S GO TO
APARTMENT OF FINANCE THEIR FILE
IN THIS. FILE THIS YEAR WE HAVE
NO FILE WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON ABC SEVEN TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD LEAVE OF ABSENCE
ON FIREFIGHTERS THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DR WHICH IS- WAIT
TESTIMONY AND WE WILL GO TO.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT SEVEN TWO THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
ONLY ROOM TWENTY FORTY TWENTY
ONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT SEVEN TWO.
AND TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT SEVEN TO PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. PICTURE WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED AB
EIGHT SEVEN TO THIS COMPANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY ONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO A.
B. EIGHT SEVEN TWO. THIS
SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
SEVEN TO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. SENATOR WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT SEVEN
TWO WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YOU HAVE A FILE. THANK YOU.
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL BENEFIT
COSTS TO CAL FIRE. A INCREASED
UNDER MODIFIED WORKERS
COMPENSATION TRANSACTIONS THAT
COULD RESULT IN THE NEED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWO POSITIONS FOR AN
INCREASE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. IN ADDITION CAL
FIRE ESTIMATES AN INCREASE OF
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND LIKELY ONGOING
FOR BOTH INCREASED WORKERS
COMPENSATION COSTS AND THE
ASSOCIATED OVERTIME REQUIRED.
TO BACKFILL EMPLOYEES OUT ON
DISABILITY. IS COST TO BE
ADJUSTED FIND BUDGET ADJUSTMENT
FOR THE FIRST THREE YEARS.
AFTER WHICH AN AVERAGE WILL BE
ESTABLISHED WITHIN CALPERS
BUDGET IN THE CURRENT
METHODOLOGY. AND WOULD NOT THAT
ANY REQUEST RESOURCES WILL BE
REVIEWED AND ANALYZED DURING
THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR
QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION- AB EIGHT
SEVEN TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON A. B. NINE FIVE FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK ON
HIGHWAYS ENCROACHMENT PERMITS
AND BROADBAND FACILITIES. THE
AUTHORS WAVED PRESENTATION AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATES
AND WE HAVE SOMEONE IN THIS
ROOM WHO WILL TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF. AB NINE FIVE FIVE.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURST THE BURNING
OROZCO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF AB NINE FIVE FIVE. LIKE TO
THANK MR MACKENZIE FOR GREAT
ANALYSIS. YOU DID A VERY NICE
JOB PUTTING OUT THE HISTORY OF
THE CALTRANS RESPONSE TO
CALTRANS APPROACH SPENT FOR
ENCROACHMENT PERMITS. THEY HAVE
DONE ABOUT 89% OF THEIR PERMITS
HAVE BEEN. ISSUED WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS WITH THE GOAL OF 95% SO
THAT'S A VERY GOOD BUT WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF BROADBAND
PROJECTS THAT HAVE RESULTED. IN
HUGE DELAYS WE HAVE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN DELAYED BY TWO
TO FOUR YEARS. EIGHTY NINE FIVE
FIVE WILL HELP ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS WE HOPE TO GET YOUR
SUPPORT BUT- AS YOU NELSON'S
NOTED ITS VOLUMETRIC. THE
NUMBER PROJECTS THAT ARE
DELAYED. I THINK AGAIN CALTRANS
DONE A FAIRLY GOOD JOB BUT WE
DO HAVE SOME PROJECTS THAT DO
REQUIRE EXTRA ASSISTANCE I
THINK WITH BROADBAND BEING AT
THE CORE- PRIMARY ISSUE THIS
YEAR. IS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SEE NO ONE ELSE
IN THIS ROOM A ROOM TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S NOBODY
OVER THERE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE FIVE
FIVE ON THE PHONE LINE. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
FIVE FIVE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THIS TEACHER WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT
WELL GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB NINE
FIVE FIVE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS HER KNOWN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES. IN OPPOSITION
TO AB NINE FIVE FIVE. IT IS
BEACON OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO ACUTE MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
FINANCED YOU HAVE A FILE. NO
FILE MISTER CHAIR. NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
NINE FIVE FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON A. B. TEN
THIRTY NINE FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WIN. ON MODEL CURRICULUM
FOR VIETNAMESE AMERICAN REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL GO TO
SUPPORT TEST VERY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE IS NONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE IS NONE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
THIRTY NINE. THIS BECAUSE
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED
UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT
THAT'S GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB
TEN THIRTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TEN
FORTIES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. IN OPPOSITION. TWO AB TEN
THIRTY NINE. AND TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. IN THE ABSENCE OF
NONSTATE CONTRIBUTIONS THIS
BILL WILL RESULT IN A ONE TIME
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES IN
THE LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
DEVELOP MODEL CURRICULA AS
SPECIFIED IN THIS BILL BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. DUE TO THE TIME
SENSITIVE NATURE OF THIS
REQUIREMENT COSTS WOULD LIKELY
BEGIN IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR IT
COULD RANGE FROM FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS
PER MODEL CURRICULA. BASED ON
COSTS FOR SIMILAR PROJECTS
UNDERTAKEN BY THE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL CREATES
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES BY
ENCOURAGING ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
SERVING STUDENTS IN
KINDERGARTEN TO GRADE TWELVE.
TO OFFER COURSES- ON. A
SPECIFIED IN THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TEN THIRTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A. B. TEN
FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WICKS. ON EMPLOYMENT LEAVE THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE IS NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN FORTY ONE. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY ONE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN
GO AHEAD PLEASE. MORNING A
THREE TERM MEMBER CLAIM BURKE
ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
NURSE MIDWIFE THAT THE ASIAN IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO NO SIMPLE
STRUCTURE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN FORTY ONE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSERS NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED. TO ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB TEN FORTY
ONE. AND SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO ACUTE A
MIXTURE ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
PARMA FINANCE IN AB TEN FORTY
ONE. IN FILE MISTER CHAIR. NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TEN FORTY ONE GOES
TO SUSPECTS MOVING ON A. B. TEN
EIGHTY TWO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON ON CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFITS REVIEW SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WITH THE
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM VERSION OF ANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN EIGHTY TWO. HIS BIGGEST
SUPPORT OF AB TEN EIGHTY TWO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. SURE WE HAVE LOADED UP
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE NOBODY IN THE
QUEUE SUPPORT WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN EIGHTY
TWO. BUT IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB. TEN
EIGHTY TWO. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO JUDITH MISTER.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE YOU HAVE A
FILE FILE MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT NO FILE NO QUESTIONS AB
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN EIGHTY
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON A. B. TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SEVEN MEMBER BIGELOW ON
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
ALLOCATIONS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE'LL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IF SUPPORTERS
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN EIGHTY FIVE. JUST BECAUSE
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN IN
CHEMISTRY TEACHER. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE NO SUPPORT LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION FOR AB TEN EIGHTY
FIVE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE LINES
OPPOSED AB TEN EIGHTY FIVE. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
EIGHTY FIVE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THERMISTOR SURE WE HAVE NO
ACUTE UP THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL TAKE OPPOSITION THAT WAS
OPPOSITION RIGHT. YES SIR ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT WAS
AT SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. YEAH
I LOST MY LOST MY THOUGHT ALL
RIGHT WE GOT A PART IN FINANCE.
REALLOCATING FOUR POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
EDUCATIONAL REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FUND FOR YOU RALPH
WILL REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
PROPERTY TAX RECEIPT BY THE
COUNTY SKI THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ON A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR BASIS.
THIS WILL DRIVE THE NEED TO
REDIRECT PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO THE
COUNTY'S CASE EQUAL SCHOOLS
UNDER THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. OTHER STATES
CURRENTLY- IN TEST ONE OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. WHICH
IS EXPECTED TO BE OPERATIVE FOR
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE DUE
LARGELY TO DECLINING ENROLLMENT
AND THE OVERALL AMOUNT OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND PROVIDED TO SCHOOL
STATEWIDE WILL REMAIN THE SAME.
SH THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN A
REDUCTION OF FUNDS FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS STATE
WIDE. AND OF CIRCUMSTANCES
CHANGE AND TEST TWO OR THREE OF
PROP NINETY EIGHT BECOME
OPERATIVE. SOME OR ALL OF THE
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
I WILL BECOME A NEW PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COST
AND HENCE REIMBURSABLE AT THE
STATE GENERAL FUND. HEARD FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TEN EIGHTY FIVE. WILL GO TO
SUSPECTS. MOVING ON THE AB
NINETEEN OH NINE ACTION ME ONE
ZERO NINE FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY. ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC DESPERATE
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NO
MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE. ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
NINETY FIVE. IS BECAUSE SUPPORT
OF AB TEN NINETY FIVE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WILLIAM AT THE
BURKE ON BEHALF OF CALIPHAL
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AT THE CROWD BONTA THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE WOULD YOU MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN NINETY
FIVE AND THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THIS TIME ANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB TEN NINETY
FIVE. AND SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO INCLUDE A
MIXTURE ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. LET'S GO
TO FINANCE. THE PHARMACY SHARE
OF FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TEN NINETY FIVE
ABOUT A SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON AB
TWELVE SIXTY ONE MY FAMILY
MEMBER BURKE ON CARB GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL-
GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC PROMINENCE
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SIX IN THE FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
SIXTY ONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MR WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION FOR AB TWELVE
SIXTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSES COMPANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB. TWELVE
SIXTY ONE. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
OF AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
STRUCTURE WE ARE GOING TO THE
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION LET'S GO TO. FINANCE
THE ABOVE FILE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD ESTIMATES IT WILL REQUIRE
THREE POINT SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND. TWENTY THREE
AND ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONFUND ON GOING TO
ESTABLISH THE PROCESS IS A
SPECIFIED AND ANALYZE RESULTING
DATA. TO INFORM ITS ANNUAL
REPORTS IN FUNDING PLANS. THE
BOARD EXPECTS TO USE A
CONTRACTOR TO ASSIST WITH THIS
WORK ON AN ONGOING BASIS. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS BILL IS
CONTINGENT ON AN APPROPRIATION
BY THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRES THE
BOARD TO ESTABLISH SPECIFIED
PROCESS USE WITHIN THREE YEARS
OTHER STATING THIS
APPROPRIATION. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
HEARD FROM FINANCE WE HAVE NO
QUESTION SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE. WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. WE WILL MOVE AB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF OUR QUE CON- THIS IS
A MONEY TRANSMISSION CUSTOMER
SERVICE- WE WILL GO RIGHT TO
OUR WE DO HAVE ON THIS ONE WE
DO HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS. BOB
SHOULD BE ENOUGH IN OPPOSITION
FOR ME WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO SUPPORT-
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTEEN
TWENTY. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE WE
HAVE LONG GIVEN UP. WE HAVE
NOBODY QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY TWO OH
THREE SO MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
AND THEN WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE WHO WISHES TO
OPPOSE- ADAM JAY FLEISCHER THE
MONEY SERVICE ROUNDTABLE AS OUR
PRIMARY AND THEN R. J.
CERVANTES. ON THE ELECTRONIC
TRANSACTION ASSOCIATION. YOU
GUYS HAVE THREE MINUTES BETWEEN
THE TWO OF YOU. THANKS A ONE
SAYS HE'S IN PERSON BUT HE'S
NOT. SO LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINE AND SEE IF ADAM IS HERE.
NEVADA MATURE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. CHOI ELEVEN QUEUING UP
SIR. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GIVE
ANOTHER CALL FOR ADAM FLEISCHER.
AND R. J. CERVANTES. GOING ONCE
GOING TWICE IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
AB. THIRTEEN TWENTY. IS BIG IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT
THEY MISTER OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDED APARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE PHARMACY CARE SO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY. WILL GO TO
SUSPEND TO MOVING ON AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. WHICH IS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE ON
TRANSPORTATION TRANSIT
DISTRICT. POLICING
RESPONSIBILITIES THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION VOTER
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. SPEAKING
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO INCLUDE A
MIXTURE ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR KNOWN AS
CUTE ALL RIGHT WE HAVE NOBODY
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FANS
CHEER. EVAN LOW FILE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. WE'LL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAVANT
DAYS ON PERINATAL SERVICES
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH THIS IS
A SUSPECT CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. AGO TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR FOR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. THE
SECOND SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
KNOWING QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED THE. THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. WE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
ACUTE UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MR HERE
WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
OF DUE TO THE ONGOING COSTS TO
THE GENERAL FUND NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
APPS. PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES
THE ROAD REQUIRED THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING. TO SUPPORT TO PERMANENT
POSITIONS THE ONGOING
REQUIREMENTS IN THE STATURE. R.
I. C. NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. IST GOING
TO SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON ON SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
PERSONS GRANTED THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OPPOSITE WAY PRESENTATION. OR
ANY RIGHT TO SUPPORT TESTIMONY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S SO
MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO SOMEBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSES
ANYONE ENOUGH ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. AND IS BEACON OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN CHEWED
UP MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL
GO TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IF
I MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FILE
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. VOTERS SUSPECTS WITHOUT
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS AND HUMAN SERVICES
NONCITIZENS VICTIMS THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. AND THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION THE
RIGHTIST TESTIMONY SUPPORTERS
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
YEARS OF IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO ME
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
ONE. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT S. ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THE MORNING RESEARCHER
MEMBERS CHRISTIAN RESPONSES
PARK AVENUE APARTMENT IN ONLINE
PARTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION
FOR AB FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO GERMANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE. THAT SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP
ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE. FILE
MISTER CHAIR- FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
THESE GUYS ARE. YEAH. WE'RE
WAITING ONE MOMENT BUT I'LL
READ THE AND NOTES SO THOSE ARE
ALL THE BILLS ON OUR HEARING
AGENDA TODAY- THEY WERE ALL
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CALLS TO LIFT. I WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED- IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THEIR THAT TESTIMONY IN
OUR HEARING RECORD. WE THANK
YOU AND APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
PATIENCE AND PARTICIPATION AND
EVERYONE ELSE AND STAFF WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE COMMITTEE OPEN
FOR A COUPLE MINUTES. YOU GUYS
CAN GO. UNTIL WHAT WE DISMISSED
YEAH. I'M JUST GOING TO KEEP.
BUT IT'S JUST HORRIBLE FOR
OFFICES HERE. IN THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED.